I didn't get the job I didn't do go to
the job interview I actually haven't
even applied for any jobs I'm you know
could just getting by on whatever
savings I had and what are you saying to
me how do we talk someone through that
when somebody is that agitated and in
distress the prefrontal cortex which is
the part we use for like weighing pros
and cons and anticipating outcomes and
kind of making decisions and thinking
things through is almost like not
available for some techniques you're
going to teach some money it could be
like a deep breathing techniques
meditation grounding physical activity
is really really helpful for a
dysregulated body like walking running
jumping you to swimming yoga whatever
physical activity because it's a it's a
physical manifestation of the anxiety so
you got to get the body to be able to
relax enough
for the brain to come online